you know I'm not a grass-fed person
because I feel as though it doesn't give
you the same type of fat content that a
cornfed c uh cow would have and so you
end up with a different Taste of the
beef I'm I'm a cornfed person what that
gentleman told you was absolutely true
and accurate it's exactly the way it is
but I'll put a little different slant on
it for you a grain fed animal that's
butchered would be an unnaturally obese
creature that would never survive in
nature it would not live a normal
lifespan wow in fact it probably
wouldn't live I'm just going to guess
half a natural lifespan I'm of the
opinion that even a creature that is
unnaturally obese and dying from the uh
conditions of sedentary lifestyle and
obesity probably ain't good for you